TREY: WELCOME BACK TO SUNDAY
NIGHT IN IN, FLORIDA WAS
ONCE PURPLE, NOT ANY
MORE.
MARCO RUBIO BEAT VAL DEMINGS
AND RON DESANTIS OVER A
FORMER GOVERNMENT, HOW AND
WHY FLORIDA HAS CHANGED.
FORMER MIAMI-DADE COUNTY
MAYOR, WINNER TUESDAY NIGHT,
CONGRESSMAN CARLOS GIMENEZ
IS JOINING US NOW,
CONGRATULATIONS.
IS HAPPENING
IN FLORIDA?
>> WE HAVE GOOD CANDIDATES.
WE HAVE THE RIGHT CANDIDATES
IN THE RIGHT DISTRICTS, WE
KNOW HOW TO SPEAK TO OUR
RESIDENTS, WE'RE A PART OF
THE COMMUNITY, ALSO WE HAVE
A GOOD INFRASTRUCTURE HERE
OUR PARTY KNOWS HOW TO RUN
ELECTIONS IN STATE OF
FLORIDA.
WE HAVE A CERTAIN WAY TO RUN
ELECTIONS IN FLORIDA, WE IT
RIGHT, WE WERE NOT
OUTPERFORMED BY THE EARLY
BALLOTS WITH MAIL IN
BALLOTS, WE KILLED DEMOCRATS
ON EARLY VOTES AND ALSO IN
DAY OF, BUT WE'RE CLOSE IN
ABSENTEE.
WHEN PUT THOSE TOGETHER WE
HAVE A GOOD ORGANIZATION,
HERE THAT IS WHY REALLY.
WE CLEAN THEIR CLOCK HERE IN
FLOOD, GAINING 4 MORE SEATS,
I WON BY 28 POINTS IN A
DISTRESS THAT WAS PURPLE,
SWITCHED BACK AND FORTH, NOW
I THINK IT IS SOLID RED.
MARIA SALAZAR WON BY 14 THAT
WAS TO BE TOUGHEST INCUMBENT
RATE IN THE STATE.
AND SO, UNWE SAW THAT UP AND
DOWN THE STATE, WE ARE PROUD
OF THE ORGANIZATION, AND
PROUD OF THE MESSAGE, HAD A
GREAT TOP OF THE TICKET WITH
OUR GREAT GOVERNOR, AND
MARCO RUBIO AS SENATE.
IT ALL WORKED OUT WELL HERE.
TREY: CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO
ASK ABOUT YOUR GOVERNOR AND
SENATOR, BUT BACK TO AN
ISSUE, REPUBLICANS WERE TOLD
FOR YEARS THAT THEY HAD TO
EMBRACE 7 MATTER -- CERTAIN
MATTERS WITH REPUBLICAN TO
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THAT OF THE TOLD TO
REPUBLICANS, THAT HAS NOT
HAPPEN YET, THEY STILL SEEM
TO MAKE INROADS WITH THE
HISPANIC VOTERS, WHAT
DRIVING THE BETTER
PERFORMANCE -- I KNOW THAT
COMMUNITY IS NOT A MONOLITH.
BUT WHAT DRIVING THE BETTER
PERFORMANCE.
>> IF YOU
IMMIGRATION, WE WANT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION, WE LIKE
IMMIGRATION, BUT NOT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, WE DON'T LIKE
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON IN
THE BORDER RIGHT NOW, CHAOS
THERE, ONE OF THE MESSAGE I
HAD, WE NEED TO FIX THE
CHAOS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, AND FIX INFLATION,
AND YOU KNOW TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT HIGH GAS PRICES, THOSE
ARE MESSAGES, ALSO SOME
SOLUTIONS TO THAT ALSO ONE
THING WE DI WAS ASKED ABOUT
ABORTION, MAYBE 3 TIMES,
THEN, LOOK.
I'M UNI SAID I'M IN FAVOR OF
THE RULE, AND IN FAVOR OF
STATES RIGHTS.
BUT I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF
DEMOCRAT POSITION THAT WANTS
TO HAVE ABORTION AT THE
MOMENT OF BIRTH THAT IS AN
EXTREME POSITION, I PUT ON
HAD ON AND ASKED 3
TIME AND THE THEN NO ONE
ASKED ANY MORE.
TREY: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION ABOUT FLORIDA, YOU
HAVE 4 -- POTENTIAL
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES IN
YOUR STATE.
IT IS GREAT FOR TOURISM.
GREAT FOR PEOPLE IN THE
POLITICS.
HOW WILL YOU NOT -- YOU HAVE
A VERY POPULAR GOVERNOR,
MARCO RUBIO AND RICK SCOTT,
THEN YOU HAVE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
HOW FLORIDAIANS NAVIGATE THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
>> IT IS TWO YEARS IN
POLITICS IS AN ETER NITD
AN ETERNITTY.
WE HAVE TO TOGETHER.
WE HAVE TWO YEARS TO FIGURE
IT OUT, PEOPLE.
GOOD PEOPLE FROM REPUBLICAN
PARTY WILL FIGURE OUT WHO
THEIR CANDIDATE WILL BE,
THEN WE NEED TO GET BEHIND
THAT PERSON, AND MAKE SURE
THAT A REPUBLICAN IS THE
NEXT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS
COUNTRY COULD SURVIVE
ANOTHER 4 YEARS OF JOE BIDEN
OR WHOEVER WHO WOULD SECOND
HIM AS PRESIDENT OF DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
WE NEED TO SAVE THIS
COUNTRY, IT HAS TO BE A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
TREY: SPEAKING OF COMING
TOGETHER, YOU LEAVE
BEAUTIFUL FLORIDA TO GO TO
DC, I THINK NEXT WEEK TO
HAVE WHAT COULD BE A VERY
SPIRITED CONTEST FOR
SPEAKER.
YOU ARE IN A STATE WHERE
REPUBLICANS DID WELL, I
CANNOT IMAGINE THAT VOTERS
WANT TO SEE A BUNCH OF
FIGHTING AMONG HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK WILL HAPPEN NEXT WEEK?
>> WE GO BACK IN SESSION
TOMORROW.
WE WERE TO HAVE LEADERSHIP
VOTES TUESDAY, BUT UNSINCE
WE DON'T KNOW -- YOU KNOW,
SINCE WE DON'T KNOW OUTCOME
OF THE RACE, ARE WE IN
MAJORITY OR NOT THAT WILL BE
PREMATURE.
I WOULD HOPE WE ALL COALESCE
AROUND KEVIN McCARTHY, HE
HAS BEEN A LEADER, AND WE
START FOCUSING ON REAL
ADVERSARY DEMOCRAT PARTY,
JOE BIDEN, NOT US, THE
COUNTRY WANTS TO US COME
TOGETHER, PUT OUT A COHERENT
MESSAGE OF WHAT WE WANT TO
DO AS REPUBLICANS AND STOP
THE CRAZY POLICIES OF JOE
BIDEN.
AND WHAT WE HAVE TO OFFER
THE ALTERNATIVE TO OFFER TO
AMERICA, BRING AMERICA BACK
TO PROSPERITY, ENERGY BACK
TO DOMINANCE IN THE WORLD
STOP THE CHAOS HAPPENING AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
A COHERENT FOREIGN POLICY,
THAT REALLY WE WANT AS
AMERICANS, THAT IS WHAT WE
NEED TO HONE IN ON WHAT WE
GET BACK TOGETHER.
TREY: CONGRESSMAN, I WAS
TRYING TO GIVE YOU ANOTHER
WEEK OF VACATION.